from Devastation in flooded Pakistan
to wildfires in Europe
and melting ice at the poles and Beyond
climate change is getting worse and the
window to act is closing
that's the message from United Nations
scientists releasing a landmark report
summarizing their work over the last
decade
the climate Time Bomb is ticking this
report is a Clarion call to massively
fast-track climate efforts by every
country and every sector and on every
time frame
in short our world needs climate action
on all fronts everything everywhere all
at once
the nod to Hollywood accompanies a major
shift developed Nations says the UN
Secretary General must now try to get to
Net Zero carbon emissions not by 2050
but by 2040. we have seen rich countries
going backwards on their climate policy
and uh these countries who are
historically responsible also have the
resources and capability to reduce their
emissions but also meet their obligation
of supporting developing countries who
still have a large development deficit
the synthesis report highlights why so
much more action is needed global
warming has already reached 1.1 degrees
above pre-industrial levels and at least
3.3 billion people are now highly
vulnerable to the impacts of climate
change including increasing food and
water insecurity and forced migration
and we are experiencing increasingly
severe weather events as well as damage
to Nature economies and human health
but the report is clear hope for
limiting warming to 1.5 degrees remains
every government of this world a
national and sub-national every CEO of
this world we know what to do we have
the knowledge and Technology but we need
to implement them to get to Net Zero
quickly
at its core that means rapidly ditching
fossil fuels but this is proving
difficult the UK just one of many
countries still approving new oil and
gas projects an example of the challenge
of tackling climate change and why
without better efforts globally agreed
targets may be slipping Out Of Reach
Sky News